has always blamed pro-choicers and
planned parenthood
of being baby killers because that
they've always had this narrative for
years and years and years that that
planned parenthood and abortion clinics
and pro-choice people they brainwash you
my brain wash you into believing you
should get rid of the baby
you know and they can it's kind of like
pray the gay way type [ __ ] they can
bring the woman in and and and show her
god and she'll see the way and she'll
see the light well what the [ __ ] does
god have to do with a medical decision
that has to do with you saving your
[ __ ] life or not
and the reason why the pro-life movement
has always had that stance is to not
target women directly with the [ __ ]
bow and arrow
as criminal
and this law is really inching up to
that now it's oh you're gonna be civilly
liable
you're gonna have to pay ten thousand
dollars to anyone who wants to sue you
and that's my question is how many
people get to sue that woman how many
how [ __ ] many
she can be liable for god knows how much
[ __ ] bounty
because the entire block's gonna turn
her in the entire block's gonna sue her
because they know she had a life-saving
procedure to save her [ __ ] life
like a dnc like troy's wife did
and the pro that's why the pro-life
movement when donald trump said that
they cringed they cringed because here's
one thing that the pro-life movement
knows
and this is one thing
that i think
is the miscalculation for republicans
here
is when you take the exception
of the woman's life
and the woman's healthcare choice based
on her life
her to be alive to be a mother or a
future mother to have kids or to take
care of the kids she already has you
know pro-life [ __ ]
i believe i believe what will happen
is that even even women who lean to the
pro-life side of the argument
begin
to see the pro-life movement is full of
[ __ ] [ __ ] because that's what they've
always been
full of [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's a bunch of [ __ ] christian males
telling women what to do because it's
not about pro-life
it's not because when you take the
exception